do you think you could ever get back
to a relationship that's romantic with
Cody
I'm not waiting for him if you could
reconcile
with the kids with that change
the outcome of you and Janelle
sustaining this marriage together
Cody and Janelle Brown reconcile that's
the big question asked on TLC's Sister
Wives one-on-one finale I don't just
blame myself
but I do believe that as we go through
struggles there's always plenty of blame
to spread around on Sunday's episode
Janelle confirmed they're separated
we've been separated for several months
what yeah Cody and I have separated and
I'm happy really happy
she's like yeah and I haven't missed you
much
the two called it quits after being what
they called spiritually married for 29
years and the lead up to it played out
this season on the TLC series the last
few years I've begun to wonder
if we're compatible anymore maybe this
doesn't
work anymore for me I don't know maybe
this is not a good fit maybe this
doesn't work yeah but it turns out Cody
does want to make things work under
these circumstances if I have a
relationship with a wife where we have
deep trust and we get along really
really well
that's because that relationship
communicated and worked on things and
did the right things in the relationship
and I'm sitting here with Janelle going
you're going to be comparing yourself
with Robin if I'd given her attention to
stuff like that so I want to save this
relationship and I would like you and me
this is what I'm saying to her I think
you can identify that let's be more
involved with each other in our lives we
sit here by consent being a family
agreeing to work things out together
it's all by our consent
um and once anybody feels like they're
done with it they're free to go for
Janelle it seems that ship is sailed
with Cody do you think you could ever
get back
to a relationship that's romantic with
Cody
I'm not waiting for him I've kind of
mourned that that part of our life has
gone I wasn't I wasn't heartbroken it
wasn't heartbreaking for me like it was
for Christine I'm finding so much value
and so much richness and deepness and it
increases as the years
seemed for me at least they seem to as
the years progress
there's more and more to it for me but
the mom of six says her faith might be
the only thing holding her back from
ending things completely it would
require so much change on both our parts
that I don't know
and part of me thinks okay
My Religion requires that you continue
to make a marriage work and I deeply
believe in my faith
and I have been at so much at peace that
I don't know how to reconcile that so
that's where my debate with myself is
all the time because I I know I'm happy
I don't want him to come back but my
faith requires that we are married
eternally
[Music]